yeah yeah and we've seen it time and
again
right yes we've seen it we've saw it
last year we've seen it from tom brady
right
we've seen it from patrick mahomes right
we didn't see it from jimmy garoppolo
when he had emanuel sanders right wide
open after the chiefs had taken the lead
in super bowl 54.
so you know it's not like some hot take
or some inaccurate read of reality
it's it that that's how it works and
those moments are fleeting
and you always think you're going to get
back remember when
dan marina well you were like three
years old but after dan mourinho lost
the super bowl the first time his
attitude was out having
you know plenty more chances no he never
had another chance yeah never had
another chance
and he didn't even have a chance during
that game to make a championship throw
because the 49ers kicked his team's ass
yeah no it's good morning you're right
hey i'm not arguing anything you're
saying we're just having some fun here
on a thursday morning but good morning
to you too and
you're right you don't know how many of
those chances you're gonna have i mean i
think you could say the same thing my
father he was in a super bowl
best day he ever had in his life and i
think he thought he'd always get back to
one two and then his team got back and
he got hurt so you just you never
know which way it does go uh and you
gotta capitalize in those moments and of
course there was there was two big
moments in that game where he didn't
capitalize
same play game play right same play
that's what makes it worse
you get me started again in the second
half after a 25 minute intermission
where they surely said hey this play
popped wide open we
we you know we threw the underneath we
didn't throw it down the field of brand
of cooks we're gonna call it again at
the right time
that's where you're going okay okay okay
and and and he held the ball too long
and he didn't throw an accurate ball and
that was that so your dad stepped up
on the biggest day of his life
professionally he did you know his whole
his whole life from from the days of the
john denver without the glasses look at
moorhead
state right right working and fighting
and scratching and clawing he got to a
super bowl and he had one of the best
days any quarterbacks ever had
on super bowl sunday he didn't have to
make a championship throw because every
throw was a championship throw that day
for him except
one yeah or two that he that he threw
what were his numbers that day 22 and 25
22 or 25
and you know he'll tell you you know
there was a drop and then there was
another one that was a past interference
uh that that he's got a case for there's
no doubt he was he could have been very
close to being 24 for 25 in the day
so uh he didn't need to throw no you're
right moments
because he had lots of them it was a
championship day for him so yeah
look and we're we're talking about all
of this because there's a rematch of
super bowl 53. tonight
between the rams and the patriots it
doesn't feel the same because tom
brady's gone but a lot of the other
pieces are the same including the pieces
on the rams including the coach and the
quarterback and we talked so much about
coaching quarterback it's the same coach
the same quarterback and we'll see if
they can get it done yeah no i mean
it's an interesting matchup nonetheless
i mean yeah it's not super bowl 53. i
don't think there's any
like personal aspect here right you know
there's too many new players on the rams
and the patriots both together to where
it just there's nothing personal about
that aspect or all we lost we still got
a bitter taste in our mouth
yeah that can happen sometimes but
either way you know the ramifications
for tonight
are are pretty huge i mean it's kind of
a must win for the patriots as we know
the rams it's not a must win but
it's a big game to where yeah seating
want to win the nfc west you know see
where you who you got to play in the
first round
all of those type of things they go into
this too and
the bigger thing is the rams have had
issues
with new england type teams this year
they have
the dolphins whoop their butt down in
miami brian flores from new england
the new york giants gave the rams early
in the year
all they could handle when the giants
weren't even playing good yet
but again patrick graham for the new
england patriots
there is obviously some common knowledge
within that coaching regime or coaching
tree
as far as how to be a pain in the butt
for this mcveigh offense i think that's
really one of the more intriguing things
about the match-up tonight
you were talking about that during the
dolphins rans game earlier this year
wha what is it that that is is
detected right by the belachekian
coaching fraternity when it comes to the
rams offense
it's the five and six man fronts to stop
the speed sweep
inside outside zone combination right
mike i mean we watch the rams every week
it's
you know fake the speed sweep there goes
robert woods flying by
and then it's you know either give it to
him or hand it to the running back and
because
robert wood's flying by a lot of the
times he opens up these weak side gaps
because people go with him so now the
running back gets the ball
and people on the back side have flown
away from robert woods because he's
flying out that way
and that gives the running back the oppo
opportunity to make a cutback and
there's usually a big lane there
new england found out and you know in
the super bowl they were one of the
first to do it where
five and six men line yes you could
always have a guy
there ready for robert woods to take
that
aspect away and now we can use the other
guys to kind of stop the run game itself
and stop the actual running play
and that was one of the one of the basic
things they did that has given that
offense a problem and the giants and the
dolphins both did that alike
i think that part of it too uh beyond
that
is just the relentless pressure on jared
goff who is one of those quarterbacks
sure
it can't really do a whole heck of a lot
when there's pressure in
his face not that there are many who can
but he's clearly in the category
of the guy that that can't buy time
with his legs you see a lot of the same
rollouts that we see from kirk cousins
and whatnot
but when he's under duress right you
know it's kind of like the
the the slow-motion gangly and i'm sorry
but that's just kind of the way he's
built you know he's
and and i i i he you there are issues
with his throwing motion
there it's amazing he's i you know i
want to be more charitable to jared goff
it is kind of amazing he's gotten this
far when you watch him play isn't it
yeah
it is i mean you know again he he's the
moments of him being able to carry the
team
at least for me are few and far between
i mean this is this is something we've
discussed a lot
hey when mcveigh and his little you know
formula plays are really clicking on all
cylinders and he feels like he's got a
defensive and a bind
man then jared goff looks great because
now the bootlegs like you said and the
screens
and the play action passes are wide open
and that leads him to getting into a
good rhythm and then the drop back pass
game starts to look pretty good off of
that too because
hey he's feeling good i'm getting
completions all over the field
it's the games where new england and the
super bowl
miami this year hey the giants even
though they won that football game
and there's you know the 49ers when okay
there's a knowledge of the mcvay formula
because the 49ers have that too because
kyle shanahan was with mcveigh of course
to where okay now those tricks have gone
away now
is jared goff going to beat you and has
he done has he beat teams
he has definitely but like i said it's
few and far between there
and i think that's the big thing tonight
because of new england secondary
they're going to be able to put a lot of
people at the line of scrimmage and stop
you know these combinations that mcvay
runs and that's going to make
jared goff have to drop back and make
throws in the football game and
ultimately i think that's where he's
going to come down to can he make a
handful of throws tonight
and not turn the bull over and get
positive results out of it to where they
win the football game he throws an
interception or two
they'll be flirting with fire and then
they might find a big l
uh after this game's over as we have
this conversation
i'm perplexed about the fact that the
rams are favored by five points
according to our friends at points back
i thought it was a little much when i
saw that last
night yeah yeah i was i was doing our
eyes
our picks later today the pft pm chris
sims on button mega pix podcast i have a
feeling we're both leaning in one
direction
let me well yeah throw a curveball out i
want to throw a curveball at you sure
because this
speaks to something that shereen
williams and i were talking about
earlier this week on pftpm because one
of the things that
that really confuses me about the nfl
when it comes to looking for coaches
is that more teams don't try at least
try to engineer a transaction where
you compensate some other team for the
opportunity to
lure away their head coach right that it
isn't even attempted very often
john gruden herm edwards when the jets
were ready to get rid of him anyway to
the chiefs
right they tried to get jim harbaugh to
the browns back in 2014-ish
let me let me just there's a lot of
assumptions here
but i'm fascinated by this possibility
and you tell me if you're sean mcvay
and the chargers come calling and they
work out some sort of a deal with the
rams let's
again that's a lot of assumptions it is
yes if you're sean mcvay
and all other things are equal and
you're showing up to work in the same
stadium anyway
would you rather coach the current
collection of rams players
or the current collection of chargers
players oh i you know that
it's it's a close one it is yeah i mean
you're right it's a
because there's some young talent on
that chargers team and of course you got
that quarterback there
that is very special and can do all the
things i believe
that we just kind of talked that are not
jared goff's strengths like
justin herbert is a guy that has showed
me enough in moments and
you know what he's done throughout the
year consistently to go oh in the future
he could be a guy jump on my shoulders
guys i got this
i'm going to make plays i'll make throws
i'll get us in the right play
and carve you up but i don't there's
something to be said about the culture
he set forth there with the rams
aaron donald jalen ramsey you know
a good group of receivers and things
there i i don't know if i would abandon
ship for that
i don't know if i would is is is good
you don't like the chargers receivers i
i don't know i do i just don't know if i
could if i'm shawn mcgood they are
they're great there's a lot of good on
that chargers team we know it doesn't
make sense that they're three and eight
when you have a top ten defense in the
top ten offense that that kind of just
says it all
that there's been something messed up
there but no i think mcvay has
got something special there they've got
championship pedigree
they're battle tested i know he could
probably bring that there too
but you don't abandon what you got right
now to go across town and go to the
chargers which are
you know yeah my point is it's a lot
closer
than you would think it is on the
surface it's a lot of that is a hundred
percent it would be a tough decision to
make a hundred percent
it is a lot closer yes there there's a
lot of positions i think you could go
through and go no i think the chargers
you know they're units better than the
rams here their units better than the
rams here
so it is it's a lot closer than the
wreckers with records would suggest
that's for sure
and for the rams the record suggests the
inside track to winning
a highly competitive nfc west that has
gotten
less competitive in recent weeks because
the cardinals have fallen off but as of
right now points bet has the rams at a
minus
143 proposition to win the division that
means you bet 143 bucks you win 100 if
they win the division the seahawks
are in second position at plus 120
they're currently
holding on to the number five spot they
don't have
much margin for error and there will be
a ram seahawks rematch coming up in a
couple of weeks the game we were talking
about yesterday that we're looking
forward to seeing play out
do we think the rams win this division
right now if you got to
pick one or the other nfc west champion
or
not what would you go with i would i
would say yes right now
um you know tonight i haven't wrapped my
head around who i think i'm gonna pick
to win that football game yet but
after that it's jets come on and then
it's seattle
and arizona and i like how they match up
with both of those football teams i mean
we've seen
i mean they they gave russell wilson and
company all they could handle and
kyler murray looked about as averages
he's looked in his nfl career last week
against the rams so for that yes
i do and tonight's gonna be you know of
course like we talked about a close
football game
and we talked about all those like
positives and things new england has the
advantage of the rams on offense
but the other side of the ball man that
rams defense is the real deal too i mean
i don't know mike we we could see a 9-6
a
13-10 game a lot like the super ball all
over again
because i have a hard time thinking that
the patriots as great as their run game
is and everything there
i have a hard time thinking they're just
going to run the ball at will on the
rams who have good cover guys and again
just like the patriots will be able to
go
we can load the box and stop the run and
trust jaylen ramsey
on nikhil harry or whoever is playing
receiver that's not that dangerous for
the new england patriots
and that's where i think we're going to
see a defensive struggle tonight
yeah and it was a defensive struggle for
most of super bowl 53 and
and you don't have tom brady and rob
gronkowski to connect with a big play
that kind of popped it all open
that's going to be the challenge at some
point cam newton's going to have to make
a play
with his arm right and do we have faith
that he can make a play with his arm
when he's got aaron donald in his face
and jaylen ramsey out there tracking
whoever his best receiver is tonight
yeah that that's gonna be the big thing
of the game i think they will be able to
protect him
just because of their run game and they
do such a good job
up front of you know being in the right
place and they're not going to let aaron
donald get too many one-on-one
opportunities but i can't imagine
throwing the ball being real successful
for this this new england team tonight
no
i mean you you said it this the
secondary for the rams young but
talented
very talented brandon staley in his own
right is
belichickian and his weekly defensive
game plans where he's he's awesome he's
a rising star in the business so
uh i i even with all that the rams know
the patriots are going to run the ball
and they're going to load the box and
you know what the patriots are going to
do they're going to still run the ball
they're gonna still go
we don't give a damn there's nine guys
there this is what we do we're gonna run
the football
and it's gonna be a battle of wills
because the patriots they they can't
play any other way
so they're used to it they're not like
oh we're outnumbered in the box and now
we're gonna throw the ball to our great
matchup
out here no they just go all right guys
we've been teaching all week
this is the best play we can do against
this front let's figure it out let's
block it boom bam boom and see how it
goes
and more times than not they open up and
move people and and do that
so uh that's where it's gonna be fun to
watch because the rams are not real
big up front they're gonna have to do it
with numbers not actual size and girth
and this is a critical game for the new
england patriots yes it's important for
the rams but they can
get away with an l tonight and still
find their path to january
the patriots on the other hand at six
and six
in a highly competitive afc
they lose tonight they may be done steve
kornacki had the playoff percentage at
21
for the patriots even after they
obliterated the chargers
in the same stadium where they'll be
playing tonight 45 to nothing
21 i like those well i don't like 21
i think the patriots have a better than
21
chance in my own kind of pasta and
meatballs gut
feel just because i'm yeah i'm tainted
by the last 20 years of what we've seen
sure patriots get into a bind they find
a way out of it it's not going to be
easy
but it does begin tonight they need this
one badly chris
and they don't have an easy road no
they've got they've got the bills and
the dolphins
lurking that is not uh the
the the the quickest and simplest path
to the post season if the patriots get
there
they will have earned it yeah there's no
i mean toughest schedule in football
this year
and i don't think it really like it
beared out any different
it wasn't like the year started we're
like all the teams we thought were going
to be good were crappy and all that
now they they got everybody that was
good and everybody that was supposed to
be good was was good and that's a pain
in the butt but
how can you count them out you know
you're right it's a must win game i
think if they lose i i really don't see
how they can
they can make it happen i mean they're
just they're going to have to you know
too many miracles will have to happen at
this point but
they we how many times have we counted
them out this year i mean the ravens
game didn't think there was any chance
they could win that i mean can they
contain kyle or murray because they
couldn't contain desean watson the week
before can they do it to kylo ren oh bam
they did that no problem
you know have beat the raiders we've
seen them beat quality football teams
and we know they're going to come up
with a proper game plan tonight to
put their team in the best chance to win
the football game but
you know to mike like must win played
four days ago and i don't know
i mean i'm looking at pro football talk
yesterday is do they have the longest
injury list in football this week i mean
they're a beat up football team too that
worries me about tonight a little too
yeah i never quite know with bill
belichick though you're right
he has a tendency to put 30 gallons
everybody on one is questionable yeah
so uh yeah i and and they went out to la
for this trip
and and i just wonder how much
winning 45 nothing as easily as they did
in such a fluky way
how do you clear that that it's a
positive fog
but how do you how do you go back to
zero zero to start another game
when you have so easily rolled up that
many on a team like the chargers
that i think that makes it harder to get
back on the horse four days later i
think you need more time
to recover from and accept the fact that
those games don't happen very often at
all and don't think that all of a sudden
you're going to start blowing people out
yeah i i i don't think they'll get to
that
i mean you're right i feel like most
teams might fall in a trap in this kind
of week
but not new england not with bill
belichick and
not with how every game has been very
hard for them this year
i mean every game so i i think they
realize like hey that was a great break
oh my gosh that was unbelievable
but hey let's not forget we had to drive
down and be perfect twice
to beat the jets in new york and you
know they've had a lot of other games
where
they they had to play their best the
last few drives of the game to beat a
team that was not
very superior or very good in general so
i would have a hard time thinking they
lose sight of that fact
and they're gonna be on their game and
realize the importance of uh tonight and
what it's all about
they have 15 players on the injury
report
going into tonight's game and they all
have the label
of questionable every damn
one of them is listed as questionable
and
they all were limited in practice all
week long and it may just be
that he's resting these guys it could be
after playing on sunday right
and they know what they have up against
them tonight you look at the rams
the rams have one guy with a
questionable
tag and that's kicker matt gay everybody
else who's on the injury report has no
designation meaning that they are good
to go
so i i i just wonder whether this is
just part of the siege mentality that
bill belichick is trying to hammer into
his guys because he knows what
it's going to take to get to the
playoffs you could argue
their road to the playoffs the four
games that they need to get there
i'm not going to say their heart or as
hard as what it'll be
when you get there but see the thing is
the teams they're facing the rest of the
way
don't have that same winner go home yeah
the desperation that
that you have when you get to the
playoffs right so you could argue it is
harder now
because you're not going to catch
someone who's maybe
freaked out by the moment because they
know if they lose it's over any of these
teams other than the jets and it doesn't
matter it's over for them already anyway
but
for the rams dolphins and bills they can
they can get away
with an l to the patriots the dolphins
it may be a little sketchier based on
what they otherwise do
but the rams and the bills are getting
to the party even if they lose to the
patriots and i just think that that
gives it a different
a different mindset it's not going to be
easy it you could argue it's going to be
easier
for the patriots to climb the ladder in
january than it will be for them to
climb the ladder in december
well i i i hear you there i do i mean
either way
though i think like the rams tonight
they feel the pressure a little bit
they they do they know where they are
and their standings in the nfc west and
all of that
and you know after that hey
like the buffalo bills they win this
week
and beat pittsburgh and do those type of
things and i don't know you don't know
what happens with kansas city
all of a sudden they could look at
themselves when they're playing new
england going
wait we can be the number one seed i
mean what what if the chiefs lose to the
dolphins and the saints this next two
weeks what if that happens
i mean it's a very real possibility and
then everything's going to be
shook up i mean i don't think it's crazy
to think that could happen even though
it's the chiefs and they always find a
way to win but
i get your point either way and the
patriots are going to have to play just
they're gonna have to do what they've
been doing half they have to play
almost perfectly every football game
i mean it's perfect and that's where
like cam newton yeah the stats don't
blow you away or anything like that
but it's not like you turn on the film
and you're like whoa people are flying
around wide open over the all over the
field
no wonder the stats aren't good he's not
hitting people and not seeing them no
he is they're taking advantage of every
yard
in like millimeter they can possibly
take advantage of in that new england
offense and cam newton
it's throwing the ball well managing the
game the right way
not making mistakes they have no room
for error and i think
you know they'll play that way tonight
and and give her the rams all they can
handle
he's one of the 15 players listed as
questionable with the lingering abdomen
injury we fully expect that he will play
he played on sunday and there's no
reason to think that injury
was aggravated but uh look he started
off
and he was a semi shortlist mvp
candidate he had the cove diagnosis it
took him several weeks to
to fight his way back to where he was
and now he's doing just enough he's
it's it's quite a contrast from five
years ago when he was the mvp
now he's just doing enough and some
weeks it's good enough
some weeks it isn't lately it has been
good enough more often than not
and to finish where we started chris
with jared goff
you know this is a test for him too
between the ears
can he step up against this patriots
team if they are confusing him at the
line of scrimmage if they're sending
guys after him if they're taking away
things that the rams like to do
yeah how can goff react and if there is
a play that
sean mcveigh has concocted that will
spring a guy wide open
will goff make the throw this time
that's really the question wouldn't that
be great there's no brandon cooks
right but they still have robert woods
and cooper cup you pop one of those guys
wide open he's going to see him and he's
going to make the throw you know you
know what they call that you know what
he's got to do right
well it's not a championship throw
because the championship isn't on the
line well it's a practice
it's a practice it's a practice for the
championship no it's not
it's not it's not there's only there's
only that moment once in your life
if you're lucky there's two right and uh
jared goff is trying to get back
to be in position to have that second
shot to do what he failed to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports